we have two more talks we're going to
have two more keynotes
Karen Sita will talk in just a second
and and dr. Pachauri will follow but so
a current sort of late edition but we're
fortunate have Karen Seto heroes who is
the coordinator coordinating lead author
of the IPCC chapter on human settlements
infrastructure and spatial planning this
is a new chapter in the latest IPCC
report Karen's a professor of geography
and urbanization at the at FES at the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies and she's also
co-chair of the future earth project on
urbanization and global environmental
change her research is focused on urban
land use change forecasting urban growth
and environmental consequences of urban
expansion and her she specializes in
China and India where she's been working
for the past 15 years so please welcome
Karen Sita thanks mark it's nice to be
here and fresh off of the IPCC plenary
from last week I taught my class this
morning class call climate change
mitigation in urban areas and I gave
them to the up-to-date blow-by-blow what
happened last week in Berlin so anyhow
it's nice to be here to be added on last
last minute I have just a few minutes
before patchy comes up and gives the
final keynote what i thought i would do
is give a very broad overview on really
the three key messages that came out of
working group three of the IPCC and then
I will I thought I would then zoom in on
the six key messages from the new
chapter the chapter on human settlements
infrastructure and spatial planning just
a little bit of background I imagine
everyone in this room is familiar with
the IPCC reports but just to give a
little bit of background on this
particular report of working group three
it is a labor of love that involve
hundreds of scientists from around the
world the the timeline for this report
actually started in 2009 with a scoping
meeting that took place in Italy we're
about a hundred so scientists came
around from around the world to identify
the to develop the annotated outlines
for what would be the working groups one
two and three reports so really the
planning for working group three started
in 2009 but the writing itself only
began in 2011 so the report working
group 3 has 16 chapters there are 235
lead authors and coordinating lead
authors but if you add the contributing
authors as well that actually boosts
this number from 235 up to well over 500
so really it has involved a number of
authors from around the world the final
report is more than 2,000 pages and
includes almost 10,000 references and
and underwent three different rounds of
peer review that included more than
38,000 comments and yes we responded to
every single one blind by line so as in
terms of the main key messages from
working group through there are really
three messages and really they're quite
simple as well me the first message is
not a very optimistic one and that is
that global greenhouse gas emissions
continue to increase and they've been
increasing at a increasing rate over the
last decade and this is despite
increases in mitigation efforts all
around the world so what we're seeing is
that although we're seeing increases in
mitigation efforts and and mitigation
policies at the national level at the
sub-national level and also at City
levels we're seeing that emissions are
continuing to rise the majority of the
increase in emissions comes from the
combustion of fossil fuels and also from
industrial processes
the second key message from working
group three is that these emissions are
rising and they're rising along with
growth in GDP and also population growth
and here one of the key findings of the
report is that this rise in emissions
that parallel of the growth of GDP
really reverses a long-standing a trend
of decarbonisation of energy so the
second key message is also not very
optimistic the third key message is that
we really need to undertake deep cuts
now in the very short term that without
more mitigation in the very short term
it's likely that global mean surface
temperature might increase by over three
degrees c and up to almost five degrees
c over this entire century so here the
key message is that we need to do
something soon and that if we do
something sooner we would actually
reduce the risks in the long run so
those are the three key messages from
the report missions are increasing
increasing at a higher rate we're saying
that if we don't make deep cuts in a
very short term that global mean
temperature may rise between three and a
half to almost five degrees C over this
century I want to spend about five
minutes just discussing the main
messages from the new chapter on human
settlements infrastructure and spatial
planning and also give a little bit of
context about why this new chapter was
developed so in the past the IPCC
reports especially working group three
reports have focused on mitigation from
a sector perspective what what are the
mitigation options from the energy
sector from transportation from
buildings and from industry and in the
past the issue of how cities and how
human settlements can mitigate and
emissions has been seen through the lens
of these individual sectors about six
seven
years ago there was a community of us
outside of the ipcc who were not
involved with the IPCC reports and we
approached a number of co-chairs and the
IPCC and said urbanization is a major
trend it's one of the biggest trends
that's facing humanity now and there's
an opportunity to think about mitigation
through the lens of human settlements
little did I know that IPCC would
actually take us up on this and so in
2009 with the scoping meeting in Italy
it was decided that there would be this
new chapter on how human settlements
would have the potential to mitigate
emissions so this chapter had to
coordinating and lead authors the other
coordinating lead author is Shobha card
to call who was out of Thailand we had
30 authors including 17 contributing
authors we have we received more than
3,000 comments there was a lot of
interest in this chapter from
governments from around the world and
our chapter alone has has almost 700
references so we have six key messages
from this chapter and the first message
is that urbanization is a global trend
and that around the world urbanization
is associated with increases in income
and that higher urban incomes are
generally correlated with higher
consumption of energy and greenhouse gas
emissions and here it's important to
point out that there are stark
differences between annex 1 and annex
two countries here on the left we have a
graph of total final consumption per
capita energy for an x1 countries and
what we see here is that in annex 1
countries urban emissions per capita and
also urban energy per capita are
generally lower than national averages
that is urban areas gender Benezet NCR
consuming less energy emitting less
emissions per capita than national
averages but we see a very different
and in non-annex one countries and in
non-annex one countries we see that
urban emissions and per capita urban
emissions and per capita energy
generally is above national averages and
this is not surprising because basically
what we're seeing is that in non nx1
countries the cities are the
manufacturing hubs that are producing
the products that we here in annex 1
countries are buying so this explains
why we see these differences in per
capita urban emissions in annex 1 verses
non annex 1 countries now the second key
message from our chapter I would say is
a message of hope and that is that the
next two decades presents a very unique
window of opportunity to mitigate
emissions in urban areas largely because
a large portion of the world's urban
areas the building's the transport
systems the energy systems have yet to
be built over the next three to four
decades we the most recent UN
projections suggest that we're going to
see somewhere between 2 to 4 billion
more people living in cities in urban
areas around the world and what we're
seeing is that over these next two to
three decades where we're going to see a
lot of new development in roads and
buildings and in energy systems and so
the opportunity here is to avoid the
infrastructure lock in to avoid the
behavior lock in that we see in high
energy consuming society so here I want
to really emphasize that this is really
a message of hope and and really an
opportunity that we really need a season
in the short term the third key message
from our chapter is that while
mitigation options really vary by by
country by by history by development
patterns and urbanization trajectories
what we found in the chapter and the
assessment is that urban or urban
mitigation strategies are most likely to
be effective when policy instruments are
bundled together and here we have a
diagram of
you're from the chapter which shows on
the first column some of the key
elements of low-carbon cities that would
for example have high levels of job
density relatively high levels of
residential density and at the same time
low carbon settlements and low carbon
urban areas will be ones that are
connected where destinations are
relatively accessible by a number of
different origins so the key here is to
bundle a number of policy instruments
together to not focus on just sector
level individual buildings or just
transport but to really think about
integrated land-use transport and urban
planning as the mitigation strategy one
of the things that we found in the
assessment is that while the next few
decades presents this window of
opportunity this window of opportunity
is going to occur largely in developing
countries and it is in the same
developing countries where there are
limited governance institutions
technical and very importantly really
limited financial capacities and here
there's a lot of discussion in the in
among the the chapter authors and also
across the different chapters on key
challenges that are around financing
mitigation strategies going into the
future now one thing that I think we've
seen here in North America and also in
Europe is that thousands of cities
around the world are implementing
climate change action plans we here in
New Haven I know there's a discussion
about a climate change action plan New
York's climate action plan is probably
among the most well-known in in the
United States what we found was that
despite thousands of cities undertaking
these climate action plans their
aggregate impacts on reducing emissions
is highly uncertain and the reason for
this is a multifold one is
that there are not standardized
reporting standards reporting mechanisms
there are a number of very ambitious
targets but again very unclear
accounting mechanisms and reporting
mechanisms and so although there are a
lot of cities around the world that are
undertaking these plans and implementing
them it's unclear what their cumulative
impacts are in the future what they will
be and then finally in terms of how
cities can implement these climate
action plans and also large scale or
urban scale mitigation what we found is
that for cities and for localities to be
effective with mitigation really
requires that mitigation action and
mitigation efforts be a linked with
local local co-benefits in other words
cities around the world especially those
in developing countries are faced with a
number of different challenges whether
these challenges are provision of clean
water energy sanitation education there
are a lot of other pressing immediate
challenges that cities around the world
face and the key message here is that
climate change mitigation strategies
that the local level are likely to be
ineffective unless they can be linked or
paired with these pressing concerns that
cities are facing around the world and
here I think this is also a message of
hope and another window of opportunity
that as cities around the world and
countries around the world are investing
billions of dollars in new
infrastructure in building the cities of
tomorrow there is an opportunity to
think strategically about building
cities that are also low carbon
settlements the chapter highlights a
number of knowledge gaps in the science
literature I list them here I'm not
going to read through them I think for
the students who are in the room this is
good news for you because if you're
interested in studying
urbanization or climate change or
mitigation of climate change in urban
areas this is a very fruitful area of
research that should yield decades of us
of science so with that I will close and
I think I have time for just a couple of
questions thank you